on termine ce journal avec une autre
idée de promenade pour ce week-end si
vous n'avez pas l'intention d'aller
porte de versailles voir le salon des
maquettes et bien vous pouvez aller à
versailles tout simplement avec les
grandes zones musical qui rouvre
dimanche au public dans le parc du
château l'occasion d'une pérégrination
sur les pattes du roi-soleil reportage
michel perrier et jacques jr
à
il y a trois cents ans les meilleurs
hommes de science de louis xiv se sont
mis à l'ouvragé et en réussi un pari qui
donne encore le vertige à donner de
l'eau à versailles
aujourd'hui encore au printemps les
grandes eaux musicales célèbres la
passion du roi pour ses jardins et ses
fontaines les jours en fait le roi
marchait dans un jardin car il était
très fier de son oeuvre
ce géant représente la fronde écrasé par
le 14 qui devient roi et qui gouverne
sans ministre et qui a aboli les des
gens qui prient opposants elle peut
ainsi si un échec dimanche le parc en
musique l écoute de lully ou bien
rameaux qui ont animé la vie de l'être
pour une promenade enrichie cette année
par la restauration de trois mosquées
conçus par le nôtre
là c'est vraiment le moment d'émotion
disons presque la maximale pour nous
c'est c'est cette renaissance à de ce
jaillissement de l'eau dans un décor que
l'on a complètement recomposée ça c'est
sûr que c'est des techniques modernes
mais c'est vraiment des effets des
effets history a des effets esthétiques
de lenôtre conçus par le nôtre que l'on
arrive à faire revivre et c'est vrai que
ça c est ce qui est le plus émouvant
pour nous dans cette restauration du
jardin
une promenade d'après dîner pour louis
xiv un moment féerique pour nous
le bassin l'autre d'un point de vue à
l'autre dans le parc du château de
versailles
noé portons souveraine